amine snoussi il est essayiste et celle
vue d'ailleurs de la matinale a means no
6 bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
sur la matinale de rtl france on en
parlait à l'instant les représentants du
peuple sont appelés à voter aujourd'hui
la confiance aux nouveaux membres du
gouvernement comment ce remaniement est
il perçu au sein de la population ce
qu'il suscite un espoir n'ont pas
vraiment le ya un désintérêt généralisé
de la politique en tunisie dans les
récents sondages on voit que d une
percée de certains mouvements populistes
très axé sur une restauration sur un ben
alisme un retour à un système plus
autoritaire mais cette personne existe
aussi parce qu'à une abstention et un
désintérêt grandiose de la politique on
estime la prochaine abstention à 60 65 %
et c'est quelque chose qui est très
inquiétant
ce remaniement intervient dans un dans
une continuité d'une lutte politique
entre le président de la république et
le chef du gouvernement
et c'est un peu ce qui exaspère les
tunisiens 7
cette personnification de la politique
qui qui même dans une condition
sanitaire où on a un mort toutes les 14
à 15 minutes en tunisie on a une moyenne
de 80 morts par jour pour 11 millions
d'habitants c'est s'est passé c'est
assez énorme et parallèlement on a une
situation sociale ou 35% des jeunes
actifs sont au chômage
on a des mobilisations et des
mobilisations énorme depuis quelques
jours et on a eu récemment un mort qui a
une qui a été qu'ils étaient tués par
bombe lacrymogène j'ai jeté au visage
avec une logistique qui n'a fait
qu'amplifier les tensions entre la
police et les manifestants
alors justement effectivement vous nous
en parler de cette situation
peut-être dégénéré situation quasi
explosive à cause des mesures sanitaires
aussi en ces temps de crises de pandémie
de coronavirus entre autres oui bien sûr
parce que il ya sept assez de demandes
depuis quelques années du fmi' pour une
austérité en tunisie chose que le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à faire parce
que la condition sociale est encore trop
délicate pour pour tenter des politiques
aussi agressifs et donc c'est un statu
quo c'est une absence d'intervention
dans l'économie quasiment de l'état
depuis quelques années il n'y a pas
réellement de politique publique
économie et pas parallèlement il n'y a
pas de dead aux entrepreneurs au café ou
au restaurant qui ont fermé à toutes les
petites petites et moyennes entreprises
qui ont dû eux qui ont dû qui ont dû
renvoyer des gens aux clients du qui ont
dû me qui ont dû arrêter leur activité
pendant quelques mois et c'est ce qui
serait cette mention est ce qu'il y
aurait des rôles en par exemple de ou en
tout cas des nostalgiques de la
révolution on s'en souvient la tunisie
qui fête les dix ans de cette révolution
qui qui n'a pas vraiment abouti
aujourd'hui
en fait ce qui a abouti de la révolution
c'est l'aspect libertaire c'est à dire
que cette révolution c'était un peu
celle de la classe moyenne en janvier on
dit que c'est la classe moyenne et en
décembre on dit que c'est la classe
populaire en fait ça que ça a commencé
sa émaner des quartiers populaires recul
sud pour arriver à tunis et la demande
est devenue libertaire alors que de
baser l'été social et là on retrouve la
demande sociale qui existait dans la
jeunesse de la révolution tunisienne
et cette demande sociale elle se
manifeste aussi par cette confrontation
cette relation très conflictuelle avec
la police parce qu'il ya une différence
énorme de traitement entre entre entre
les classes sociales et entre entre les
quartiers en tunisie avec avec la police
et se relance révolutionnaire il vient
de c2c de cette situation sociale qui ne
s'est pas améliorée en dix ans
merci beaucoup à vous amis mais aussi
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de france je le rappelle vous
êtes essayiste et vous êtes à tunis